that's an interesting position that the  engine was favoring even his moose over  magnus's for a while so I want to see it  I mean Knight C5 is certainly something  that I think Magnus is calculating even  right now but I mean hang on night and  we have exactly the same position in in  nodia  Nakamura game as well Knight E1 to B6  the first novelty because if I'm not  mistaken then actually did Magnus  captured on G4 I think mine was captured  first and on Queen takes before only  then did he play Knight ABS yes and then  suddenly after Knight C5 there were all  these awkward moments that he he  couldn't really get this Knight out I  couldn't kick this Knight away so it it  perfectly makes sense yeah just to play  as solidly as possible 91 to B6 on both  boards  like this we will do perfect Justice  because we are talking about the same  position  and it's it's nice to analyze both in  one get